so
[Music]
which
so
boost
the technique
it looks very simple it looks like a
wrist lock
um
let us note that
there are internal aspects
where it's not a wrist lock in the sense
that energy is actually in throughout
his whole body the wrist lock
is just in the wrist
the
energy in his body
is i'm here and you're moving you're
moving him
okay
that starts from the very beginning
so energy just in his arm
versus
getting his center
to move
those are your internal aspects
i can't quote you
your strategic aspects are one of
non-contestation
okay
so you'll have two choices
one
you manipulate his arm
to put it there
or you move to where his arm is there do
you understand
this that's jiu jitsu okay
so
if i go like this
this hand
has to be turned down into place and
then put on place okay
let's just start with the second thing
here this has to now be put on place
okay
if i move my chest to it it doesn't have
to be put on place i will make that
you get it
and
if you look at the first move
his arm is already turned his arm is
turned do you see his arm's not here
because you're in his body
and you're in position
do you think
you're not grabbing it here well guess
what
that's not the right place and what ends
up happening
is you put his fingers on you you see
which is why i counted that as not the
technique because now you force it
that wasn't the technique okay
which is why
the other one made sense to your body
you see
because the knuckles are in place
for no body
this
for the wrist lock
even this one
better move it's going to hurt yeah
you're going to move don't exist
okay
but then what we're doing is on the
chest
so it's in his body
not in his wrist
move
in his body and i move my
shoulder to where it needs to be
it'll change every time it depends on
what he do what he does
you see depends on what he does
there
right there
boom
so i'm moving
to where that thing
will be in place
not moving his arm
onto me
okay and that is just straight jiu jitsu
you always do that okay
you're always supposed to do it so i
move
home it's in place
pull
in place
there's no turning of the wrist to turn
the wrist i would have had to have been
stronger than
it turns on the kazushi
right there
in his body
once you get in place
some of you
sometimes you're here
but then you crying on his wrist
and it slips
and it goes down your blood
will
use this in his body
in his mind
see
not just in his wrist
in his
body in his body
who
there is
in his body
same cook
same tokyo there
same right here
in his body still in his body
in his body
on in his body
on
his body
it doesn't have to be big
i just made it big
you can do it small
on
but
i'm moving my body
to where it is
and on the first part
we're starting what you need okay
but you always have to get out of the
wrist
huh
uh here you go
well it's in place right it's not it's
not on can you see it's it's only uh
it's open do you understand okay
uh
the same thing that moves him
whoa
is the same thing
uh
when i'm here and feel that
okay what do you feel now
okay
uh
pull your hand down
okay
now i want you to understand it in terms
of friction you got it okay whoa
hair
here do you feel the friction you think
try to pull your hand out
[Music]
and that's the friction that moves hip
that is ikey okay all right now you go
like this and it slips down as you see
and you start to lose it
you want instead if you're in his body
and you're in his body okay
through that adhesion all right yeah
okay cool i want you to note how it's
actually pretty tight
you see it's pretty tight in terms of
your ability to pull out you get it even
though
it's not closed it's not closed right so
this same energy you see how i can pull
him in with it
cool tight it doesn't slip down on my
body
pull tight
tight
okay
hey
when you guys go to do your wrist locks
you're actually
taking it off
okay
leave it on leave it on here you feel
the same friction do you see same
friction same
friction
so don't push it off for you in your
attempt to hurt him
leave it on you leave it on
leave it on it doesn't slip off
does not slip off
okay we talked a lot on those last two
parts so i'm not going to say it all
again i'm just going to demonstrate it
so again in summary
uh
as in the podcast today he has to
organize his body a certain way he has
to work with energy a certain way a
prescribed way which designates the art
and so does uke
and both are doing the exact same thing
but he's doing it from yong and i'm
doing it from yin as a result of that
as he tries as a young from a young
aspect to put energy into the whole of
my body i as spoken let that energy go
into the whole of my body i organize
myself
and when i do that
i also do not localize
the wrist lock
okay and then i don't get hurt and then
i put more of my mass into the technique
and he has to do his part much better
because he experiences me as more
unified and thus more heavy okay so i
just want to show you kimmy aspect of it
again okay so my whole body is organized
and you can see there's no need to go
but you can see i disorganized and now
his energy is going to get localized
it's going to move my whole body
so i don't risk injury
because energy is dispersed
next point
pay attention to the album
as i let energy go throughout the whole
of my body
energy remains constant
throughout the whole of the body of the
technique
in nico
it's going to be the elbow so i pay
attention to the elbow energy
meaning
i come into his whole body
through his elbow through his elbow
not his wrist
so i go in
it's his elbow
elbow
elbow see right
now i reach the end of my range of
motion and the elbow is off
so to transfer that energy
just like you can transfer the energy
from the yin perspective
i have to transfer the energy
[Music]
in the whole of this point
not
on
off
it's on
all the way to the end
elbow
this elbow
all the way to the end
not here
off
i
in his body
[Music]